haha the Joe Rogan experience yeah you
can go the other thing is strange is
that you consume the media you know like
the news of it oh my god is going on and
then you can walk down a street or drive
down the street and forget but you know
I mean like there's this sense of yeah
what so I talked about another cousin of
Mines a doctor and she's like oh I yeah
I don't I don't turn any of it on I just
get it out of already know like what's
happening so I just choose not to have
be bombarded by it yeah you can be
bombarded yeah you know and it also
shifts your your view of the world so it
can heighten your anxiety and your
paranoia we people who are anxious
already people already have anxiety
issues they must be a [ __ ] wreck
right now absolutely because they
they're like oh my god I was right the
world is ending there's a mandatory
lockdown across the entire country
except Montana it's weird to have this
going on honestly and promote you know
like it's like there's so many people at
home so me people at home I mean I look
I understand the whole marketing of and
how that works but you're just like you
know you're on these calls and they're
like tell us make a new special isn't it
crazy there's a pandemic so what did you
guys shoot it yeah what do you mean by
ball hog
and why do you have all those pornhub
girls they're saying ball hog yeah did
you get those girls to say that are they
already saying ball they're already
saying it the you talking about my
stories yeah yeah they were already that
that's where I got the title I was on
the road that was Jay and my D well and
I saw I saw a nice lady doing really
extensive stuff - this guy's balls right
and I was like I wonder if there's a
whole sub-genre dedicated to this you
know so I typed it in and they're like
you might enjoy ball hogs so in that
feature these ladies they introduce
themselves and they go and I'm a ball
hog so yeah they all do it and they
really work on guys balls like hardcore
really bad and so in the special I
one point just reference I not that film
but I just tell people that that their
mothers are ball hogs and then and then
I think I think though you're really
good this by the way
picking titles I think it's one of the
hardest things you know you're like
you're doing your edit and you just want
your show together they're like we're
gonna call it [ __ ] no live from here
it's just the worst but yeah you've had
good ones but anyways I was going back
and forth with different titles and it
was suggested actually Josh my manager
was like wow and I smiled ear to ear and
I was like yes at that point what was
your tour named take it down oh yeah you
can't call it take it down can't call it
take it down no I mean you could but no
no you can't call hogs better yeah yeah
yeah it was funny when you call it tour
one thing and then you call the special
I know and people were like you should
call it take it down I'm like yeah but
they they don't want it to be called
take it down yeah
they don't Netflix isn't like you it'd
be great if you call this take it down
[Applause]